bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ski mag c'est la rentrée cette année
les étudiants ont réintégré les cours en
présentiel de nouvelles écoles et
formations ou vu le jour nous nous
rendrons à l'école de 1600 qui propose
une formation en cyber sécurité en
alternance nous ferons le point sur les
nouveaux enseignements dispensés au sein
de l'université versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et à l'estaca école
d'ingénieurs nous irons à la ferme école
graines d'avenir qui ouvrira bientôt ses
portes enfin à nous irons à la rencontre
de philippe dit guen élus du territoire
qui répondra à nos questions sur
l'enseignement supérieur ont fait le
tour de cette rentrée c'est parti
[Musique]
cela me rend compte qu'on a attendu et
ennui effectivement très heureux de
pouvoir accueillir les étudiants en
présentiel à l'université oui on a fait
une belle rentrée en accueillant tous
nos étudiants présentiel ça nous a tous
fait réveillez vous il ya plus de dix
ans les gens victimes
du coup c'est cool de les revoir ça
faisait très longtemps que je n'avais
pas revu mais tous mon pied levé de
retrouver en présentiel enfin le contact
avec une partie rectum ans pour tous
sens pour se concentrer ça donne plus
envie de travailler
qui explique t elle fini les cours à
distance cette année les élèves ont pu
réintégrer les classes et les amphis ce
qu'on peut retenir c'est le coup je
crois le bonheur partagé de pour les
enseignants de retrouver leurs étudiants
puis pour les étudiants aussi qu'ils ont
été coupés de leurs
enseignants de pouvoir retrouver les
bancs de l'université et les
interactions même entre la vie
associative enfin tout ce qui concourt à
la vie d'un étudiant en temps normal une
normalité crucial pour l'université
saint-quentinoise qui fête ses 30 ans
cette année et espère bien pouvoir
programmer divers rassemblements 30 ans
et une renommée internationale
chaque année ce sont près de 20 mille
étudiants qui viennent s'y former en
formation initiale continue ou en
alternance les différents sites compte
1000 enseignants chercheurs du véhicule
est aussi implanté au sein de
l'université paris saclay classée 13e
parmi les universités internationales
dans le classement de shanghai nous
sommes très très heureux et très très
fier de concourir à ce positionnement de
l'université paris saclay l'université
paris saclay c'est là la première
université en france la première
université de l'union européenne donc on
est très fiers puisque effectivement nos
chercheurs donc au laboratoire concours
à 7 à cette treizième place autre fierté
son classement mondial dans le domaine
des sciences de l'atmosphère
en janvier 2021 l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
situé au sein de l'ue vs cul et
hébergeant le latmos lançait un âne ou
satellite lu vs cul ça tu le premier
satellite universitaire le but parvenir
à une constellation de nano sat ce
premier succès à encourager la
conception d'un second danos at
actuellement à l'oeuvre
[Musique]
impulsé également de nouvelles
formations pour cette rentrée une
nouvelle licence professionnelle
dispensée dans les iut a vu le jour le
bachelor universitaire de technologie ou
dut
ceci répond à la réforme engagée par le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur on
a également en outre cette année une
licence professionnelle dans le domaine
bancaire sur le middle back office on
est au contact des entreprises du
territoire et on sait que le tissu
économique est extrêmement dense sur
saint quentin et là notamment la licence
professionnelle middle back office c'est
parce qu'on travaille étroitement avec
un établissement bancaire du territoire
et qui avait un besoin de formation et
donc le diplôme a été montée c'est l'ufr
des sciences sociales qui qui porte sa
ltée a été monté en collaboration pour
que l'information correspondent bien aux
besoins des professionnels du vécu c'est
aussi montrer à l'écouté du milieu
hospitalier un diplôme universitaire sur
le management des structures
hospitalières et de santé a été mis en
place y compris dans le cadre de la
formation continue
[Musique]
d'autres innovations sont à l'étude
comme le projet d'hôpital virtuel c'est
à dire être capable de créer des
structures de recherche et d'accueil des
équipes médicales il ya cette dimension
là est également une dimension
innovation puisque dans l'hôpital 2.0 on
va dire on devrait accueillir des
matériels travailler très étroitement
avec les entreprises les plus innovantes
dans ce secteur là pour pouvoir tester
justement les matériels les innovations
et puis a aussi une dimension formation
un système de formation et aussi de
formation continue de développement
professionnel continu du secteur de la
santé et enfin il ya une dimension
territoriale d'offre de soins puisque
cet hôpital virtuel il accueillera des
cabines de téléconsultation on s'appuie
beaucoup sur les acteurs du territoire
que ce soit saint quentin ou le conseil
départemental qui nous accompagnent nous
aide énormément et c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à fonctionner à tuer des projets
[Musique]
direction l'estaca ou la rentrée fut
tout aussi active une rentrée repensé on
a fait un accueil un petit peu
particulier pour les premières années
cette année tous les nouveaux élèves on
les a accueillis avec l'idée qu'on
voulait tout de suite leur donner un
petit peu les valeurs de l'école qui
sont la lutte contre les discriminations
et puis toute la thématique de la
transition énergétique et la
sensibilisation à l'urgence climatique
l'estaca qui forma à la mobilité de
demain dans l'automobile l'aviation
l'espace et le ferroviaire à ajouter une
autre corde à son arc le naval ça répond
à une forte demande aussi des
industriels dans ce domaine là et puis
on avait aussi une demande de nos de nos
étudiants qui sont assez intéressé aussi
par par le naval la filière navale
effectivement l'estaca y pense depuis
longtemps ça a été réfléchi avec les
entreprises
on a aussi ouvert le une formation en
apprentissage
donc c'est une formation d'apprentissage
à partir de la troisième année chez nous
pour des niveaux ingénieurs sur tout ce
qui est les véhicules autonomes qui est
aussi un domaine dans lequel il ya un
gros besoin d'ingénieurs cette formation
d'apprentissage en fait elle était elle
a d'abord été proposé dans le cadre de
la formation continue aujourd'hui elle
est ouverte à des étudiants bas qui
arrive alors il faut qu'ils aient au
moins deux ans d'études niveau dut bts
licence ou classes prépas accepté pour
préparer en alternance ce diplôme
d'ingénieur
côté vie associative les cela a choisi
d'encourager et de soutenir ses
concepteurs en herbe l'école s'est dotée
d'un local de 800 m² à trappes afin que
les étudiants actifs au sein des
diverses associations de l'école puis si
le vrai et s'est évanoui
le territoire s'est aussi dotée pour
cette rentrée deux nouvelles écoles et
de nouvelles formations c'est le cas de
l'école 2600 qui dispensent une
formation en cybersécurité en alternance
mais également de la ferme école graines
d'avenir qui forment au métier de
maraîcher primeur
moi là bas je faisais un bts ainsi aux
systèmes informatiques aux organisations
avec une spécialisation systèmes et
réseaux je me suis rendu compte que le
secteur de la cybersécurité recrutait
c'est un secteur d'avenir et je me suis
dit pourquoi pas de tenter ma chance
tout simplement l'année dernière j'étais
au lycée encore j'étais en terminale et
je me suis formé en autodidacte sur la
cybersécurité sur une plateforme en
ligne il ya une véritable cohésion de
l'équipe et ça fait depuis à peine deux
semaines que la rentrée a débuté
pourtant on a déjà un esprit de corps
très avancé ça devient notre chez nous
l'école de 1600 a ouvert ses portes
début septembre avec une spécificité
l'alternance on a choisi le modèle de
l'alternance pour pour pour deux raisons
la première c'est que nous ne
souhaitions pas qu'ils aient de
barrières financières à l'entrée ont
souhaité répondre à un besoin urgent de
compétences des entreprises et le fait
que nos alternant soient placés
directement l'entreprise est
opérationnel très vite en entreprise ça
permet tait de répondre à ce besoin
urgent de compétences des entreprises
est majoritairement des entreprises du
territoire pour cette rentrée l'école a
reçu huit cent quarante dossiers de
candidatures 60 alternant ont intégré
cette première promotion le cursus de
trois ans prépare à un titre rncp de
niveau 7
ici les étudiants internes quinze jours
d'école puis quatre semaines en
entreprise pour un tiers de cours
magistraux et deux tiers en mode projet
à partir du moment où ils ont été
sélectionnés sur dossier ils ont passé
une série d'entretiens il ya eu un
premier entretien qui étaient là pour
bien évidemment leur expliquer aussi ce
qu est l école le programme est ce qu'on
allait atteindre 2 qu'on allait leur
demander est-ce qu'on allait leur
apporter aussi bien évidemment est sûre
et sentir si effectivement il allait
pouvoir intégrer avoir cet état d'esprit
cet esprit de corps avoir cette volonté
on leur demande beaucoup le cursus est
très dense donc ils vont beaucoup
travaillé on va former des experts en
cybersécurité c'est à dire des gens qui
vont à la fois comprendre les bleus un
de production de l'industrie mais avec
ce souci de caisse que potentiellement
peut mal se passer est exploité à des
fins malveillantes la sécurité
informatique
c'est pas que de l'informatique pour de
l'informatique dans un coin c'est aussi
une informatique qui s'inscrit avec des
humains au sein d'une organisation
on a besoin de tout les psychologies
possible des gens extrêmement pointue
dans un domaine qui vont être très dans
la concentration
la tâche et la l'exécution d'une tâche
mais aussi des gens très polyvalent très
en capacité de communiquer de manière
différente avec des gens très différents
et de gérer une crise
[Musique]
nous voici à magny les hameaux au sein
de la ferme école graines d'avenir qui
vient elle aussi d'ouvrir ses portes
avec un tout autre enseignements
proposés l'objectif de cette ferme école
est d'associer agroécologie enseignement
innovantes pour former des jeunes dès 15
ans au métier de maraîcher primeur ils
vont apprendre à produire transformer et
vendre des fruits et légumes frais ils
vont passer deux tiers de leur temps à
la pratique c'est à dire ils vont
réaliser de vraies commandes de vrais
clients aux conditions du marché et ils
vont aussi passer un tiers de leur temps
dans les enseignements théoriques qui
vont leur permettre de préparer le
diplôme du cerap et primeurs du titre
professionnel d'ouvriers de production
horticole à la ferme ils vont ils vont
planter cultiver tout type de légumes ça
va des légumes de conservation on a des
cours des oignons des betteraves à des
légumes primeurs salades carottes mais
aussi des légumes de saison estivaux
comme des tomates des aubergines des
poivrons les élèves vont aussi apprendre
à cultiver leurs alliés les fleurs
mellifères où les fleurs aux propriétés
auxiliaires permettent d'éloigner les
parasites ou au contraire attire les
amis des jardiniers les abeilles sont
particulièrement appréciés pour leur
rôle de pollinisateur
les coccinelles elles chassent les plus
rudes pour vendre on va faire des
ateliers théâtre on va aussi
leur faire manger le fruit de leur
travail pour qu'ils apprennent à
reconnaître les goûts l'acidité
l'amertume d'un fruit sa texture ça à
travers des ateliers cuisine ils vont
pouvoir faire des salades de tomates aux
autres et après bien mieux appréhender
les l'utilisation des frais légumes et
mieux conseiller le client derrière les
légumes seront aussi transformé jus
sauces fraîches des coupes avant
commercialisation
les cantines scolaires de saint quentin
en yvelines profit de ses fruits et
légumes frais et bio il alimente aussi
les épiceries locales et les marchés
comme celui de rungis début des cours le
4 octobre les quelques places encore
disponibles resteront ouvertes jusqu'à
fin 2021
[Musique]
bonjour philippe big n bonjour vous êtes
délégué en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur ici à saint quentin en
yvelines alors nous avons rencontré de
nouvelles formes d'enseignement de
nouvelles formations tout au long de
l'émission voilà quels sont ces
formations qui sont impulsées qui sont
nouvelles cette rentrée à 51 eglin alors
vous mettez effectivement le doigt sur
le fait que nous avons été très très
dynamique au niveau de cette rentrée
scolaire puisque universitaire pardon
puisque il y à des formations nouvelles
à titre d'exemple je peux citer l'école
de 1600 qui est spécialisée dans dans
tout ce qui est cybersécurité et avec en
plus l'avantagé d'être dans l'alternance
nous avons un nouveau campus 3,3 yes je
sais que vous vous êtes rendu également
à la ferme bull loyer est justement ces
nouvelles formations c'est aussi un peu
tout l'attrait à saint quentin en
yvelines qui est très impliqué dans
l'enseignement supérieur effectivement
nous sommes nous avons entre autres deux
gros atouts sont notre agglomération qui
est le tissu économique mais également
l'enseignement supérieur et l'objectif
de de l'enseignement supérieur c'est de
s'adapter au monde économique c'est pour
ça que nous devons perpétuellement être
être en mouvement être à l'écouté des
entreprises et c'est à ce titre là
d'ailleurs que nous avons créé cette
année le rayon le réseau que nous
appelons sky shops c'est-à-dire un
réseau entre le monde de l'enseignement
supérieur et le monde de l'entreprise de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent dialoguer
de façon très récurrentes est ce qu'il y
à d'autres pointent d'autres surprises
je pense notamment à
l'hôpital du futur alors l'hôpital du
futur ça n'est pas une surprise mais
c'est une continuité nous avançons dans
cet objectif d'hôpital du futur
d'ailleurs un comité de pilotage a été
créé sous la responsabilité de
l'université
de saint quentin à laquelle bien entendu
l'agglomération participent nous savons
également que le département sera
fortement impliqué dans le financement
de cet hôpital du futur nous attendons
également la région bref cela cela
avance et ne je pense que dans le
courant de cette année nous allons
passer une étape décisive pour cet
hôpital du futur et dans le domaine de
la santé qui est absolument nécessaire
merci beaucoup filet guiguen pour toutes
ces précisions ski mag spécial
enseignement s'est terminée très bonne
rentrée à toutes et à tous ciao
[Musique]